you
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to this
afternoon talk my name is Sid Chaudhary
and I have here Karthik with me we are
both from yuca byte we are a open source
distributed SQL database built for the
modern cloud native error so that you
can run it in you know public cloud VMs
as well as containerized kubernetes
based architectures with that I will get
started and then I'll bring on Karthik
in the middle of the talk to take us
through the remaining part thanks
Karthik thank you so let's get started
with a little bit of orientation so that
we know what space are we talking about
there are two types of data stores in
the extreme one is called an analytic
store or the common term is an OLAP
store the other extreme is an OLTP store
or a transactional store there are
distinct access patterns that each one
of these stores are built for if we take
the OLAP side then the data is gets sort
of written to that data store once
that's every night then it is read many
ways again and again it has got few
concurrent sessions because it's about
users human beings talking to it through
a live ad hoc analytic style UI and
you're analyzing petabyte scale data to
get some insights it's actually exactly
the opposite on the other side where a
transactional database has to account
for writes and reads happening at the
same instance of the time the data you
are trying to pull out is also being
written by somebody else
the chances of you getting incorrect are
very high so that's why transactional
databases ensure that you get the
correct answer all the time right
many concurrent sessions because it's
not about human beings anymore it's
about your application code that is you
know deployed probably in IOT devices
which will build millions they're all
talking to your database at the end of
the day and the queries that you are
going to run we need to come back really
fast
typically single-digit millisecond very
latency is sort of the state of the art
if you would say in transactional
databases
so the type of data is is point REITs
and short-range scans as opposed to full
table scans which is third of the
standard in our OLAP space and data
storage is typically in terabyte scale
it used to be in gigabyte scale I would
say ten or years back we are today in
terabyte scale if if data continues to
explore these things will will change
petabyte will become exabyte there are
by to become petabyte in in no time if
you have not guessed it this talks focus
is on the OLTP side of the house we're
not going to look at the OLAP side of
the house some examples to drive home
the point there are by the way each one
of them have a knows SQL flavor of what
kind of client language you talk to the
data store with and there is an SQL
flavor which is commonly known as
structured query language all of us
learn most likely as engineers most of
us learn that in school and in the OLAP
site there are a lot of players and
there are some examples to sort of drive
your thinking about who they are on the
OLT besides there are also lots of
players within both no sequel and sequel
categories for this talk we're going to
focus on OLTP SQL database okay I know
any of you are thinking it's a solved
problem what's the big deal we've been
using my sequel Postgres sequel and
Oracle for ages why change I will prove
it to you that we need to change so
let's start with why as developers will
love SQL okay first is is about the
flexibility of writing the queries SQL
is about modeling your data once in some
sort of a normalized manner laying down
the data in terms of tables and then
writing queries on day one changing
queries on day two and changing queries
on day and as our business needs change
the
is different than no SQL no SQL you
model your query first and then if you
need to change it's hard problem because
your data is already laid with respect
to the query you want to solve sequel is
very powerful about query flexibility
and also query flexibility goes
hand-in-hand with you know modeling
richness performance if you have lots of
joints lots of foreign key constraints
built into your sequel queries illah
spective whether it is a single node
sequel or a distributed sequel does not
matter it's going to take more time for
the database give you the answer back
because it is going to do more work on
your behalf right
so you but the power is in your hands is
developer to choose how you want to do
your modeling okay and that's the kind
of response you should expect from the
database secondly sequel is about rich
ecosystems almost everything that is
sequel based has a very rich ecosystem
of integrations developer tools i des
visualization tech it's all about very
easy to get started you can probably
build your own integration faster if the
database that you are talking to is a
sequel SQL database okay last but not
the least as we saw in the big data wave
and now we're seeing in the cloud native
wave its SQL is that Universal data
access language we all have learnt it
once and the beauty is that we can use
it forever
there is once you have learned SQL it's
like learning how to ride a bike you
don't forget it okay now wish it we're
all positives unfortunately there is
always something wrong with with all
these technologies why do desk 8sq first
is most SQL databases that we're aware
of was Grace my sequel Oracle sequel
server they're all monolithic databases
there is only one node that can accept
your incoming
to request and if you are serving a
high-volume application which is what
more or less the Internet era has
allowed us to do make IOT make retail
take FinTech all these are high volume
applications because millions of users
are touching them at any given point of
time your SQL database is is in deep
trouble because it does not have the
compute capacities to serve those
incoming write requests so what do as
engineers do we start ringing out how to
solve this problem there are two ways
one is we what is known as charted SQL
we create an independent instances of
SQL databases and let our application
manage which record or row is present in
which database instance remember each of
those instances don't know anything
about each other so it's all the
applications responsibility secondly we
augment our SQL database with some know
SQL but no SQL predominantly is a non
transactional technology most of them
you cannot even read the write that you
have just written into the database
given how eventual consistency and lack
of acid work in no sequel databases so
you are limited as to what exactly can
you do and immediately as a developer
you have started compromising you hate
what is going on not a happy experience
secondly it's about handling
infrastructure failures as we move to
the cloud from private data centers
infrastructure which is disc node
availability zones regions and entire
clouds they are all prone to failure
because by design the way the cloud
works it's it's massively shared
infrastructure that the cloud providers
have created for us on commodity
hardware that we all get to use on a
utility basis very different than
private data centers where we had our
own racks
our own dedicated networking and our
specialized big boxes that we bought
from IBM Dell and HP okay in that world
the infrastructure is gonna fail
absolutely and SQL databases are very
bad when it comes to handling failures
so as engineers we have to now deploy
replication schemes and manual failover
technologies to make sure that we can
handle those failures again unpleasant
experience last but not the least as we
are all building as you are trying to
draw the maximum out of the cloud
infrastructure that we are using as the
Amazon Google Cloud or Azure we want to
start building what is known as geo
distributed applications to become to
make our applications live closer to
where our users are and not just have a
single region application but all
requests tracked across the globe come
in to be served in that world your SQL
database is again another bottleneck you
can scale your application out to
multiple regions but your SQL database
has to sit in a single region on a
single instance and you have to serve
everything from there this is where it
gets challenging so that's why we are
here to talk to you about distributed
SQL simply put distributed SQL is about
keeping all the things we love about SQL
and removing everything we hate about it
what does it mean it means keeping the
SQL features intact which makes as
developers happy right and then this
horizontal right scalability fault
tolerance and globally consistent writes
are the three things that I talked about
that are bad with monolithic SQL lastly
you must be thinking I just distributed
my data that means if I ask a query the
query will get distributed and as a
result will cost me more time and
latency in order to serve the request
now if your application is architected
in such a way that majority of the time
they're actually doing point lookups and
short-range scans which is what the OLTP
workload is then you can serve it from a
single instance most of the time some
different instance depending on the
query but each request will hit only one
instance and at that time you want to
ensure that instance is able to serve
you the correct data without talking to
anybody else and that's where the low
read latency aspect kicks in so with but
these five things let's talk about the
two dominant architecture schools of
thought that have come by in the last
four five years and and sort of compare
how they deliver these benefits who was
so first is Amazon Aurora the way Amazon
describes it is a highly available my
sequel and Postgres sequel compatible
relational database service it was made
generally available in 2015 it is
Amazon's fastest ever growing service
not just fastest ever growing database
service fastest ever growing service so
clearly as engineers we love something
that or Aurora has to deliver okay
that's one secondly Google being Google
Google is not gonna leave itself behind
Google has another it's considered an
engineering marvel in its own right and
that's called Google spanner and the the
tagline from Google is is the first
horizontally scalable strongly
consistent relational database service
okay google has been using it internally
for more than a decade but Google cloud
started offering it as a managed service
starting 2017
right and if you see one of them is
based on shared storage architecture
paradigm and the other one is to is
based on a shared nothing architecture
paradigm and that's what I'm going to
talk to you about how each of these
architecture paradigm
maps to the five desired properties we
want out of our distributed SQL
databases let's dive right in
first is SQL features depth of SQL
support Amazon Aurora is fully my sequel
and post a sequel compatible so whatever
you were doing before on my sequel and
posting a sequel you can do all of that
with my Amazon Aurora it's not the case
with Google spanner Google spanner uses
a subset of SQL feature exposes a subset
of SQL features and it's not actually
standard with any of the existing open
source SQL database it's it's its own
flavor and importantly it actually does
not support things like foreign key so
it it puts a little bit of restriction
on the kind of SQL applications you can
write okay so we can say that the SQL
support is a little bit limiting in in
google spanner but nevertheless it's
still SQL you can still do your
transactions you can still do your
joints and so on let's go into the next
one horizontal right scalability now
this is how Amazon aurora looks
underneath the covers it's actually a
single node SQL running on a multi zone
distributed storage engine what do I
mean by that you see at the top those
are the SQL query layers there is one
master in the entire cluster which is
responsible for taking your rights and
serving you correct reads and there are
a bunch of replicas mark by are in there
you can talk to the arse to get some
stale reads but you can never write to
an R okay because it's a read replica at
the end of the day underneath the
storage layer is is highly available
replicated across multiple zones inside
a single region now the benefit of this
is that we can add as many read read
replicas we want in order to scale our
reads
if we have a heavily read intensive
application this is not a bad idea
however if you have a write intensive
application you are in trouble because
you cannot add more primary instances
okay that's one of the poor limitations
of the Aurora architecture spanner on
the other hand takes this problem
head-on it says that when you give me a
any SQL table I'm gonna divide into
small chunks and let's say this is a
three node cluster I'm gonna put one
third of the chunk in instance one 1/3
is instance 2 and 1/3 in instance 3 the
power of this model is that a as I can
add as many new instances I want and
spanner will automatically balance the
data in the new node so if I added one
more node it will become one fourth one
fourth one fourth one fourth okay that
allows me to actually do both the things
I can add primary instances I can add
read replicas out which are not even
shown in this this cluster diagram so
from a write intensive application
standpoint spanner is a head of Aurora
okay because it provides horizontal
right scalability third point all
tolerance as I said infrastructure is
bound to fail applications and databases
have to own the problem have to be
architected or for handling that in in
Amazon Aurora the failover is automatic
and this is very shines above your
standard relational database like
Postgres and my sequel the native
failover and repair because the movement
the M so if an R dies no problems right
I have plenty of hours lying around but
if the M dies between the remaining arts
there is something a notion of a
election election they vote and one of
them becomes an M automatically right
there is a slight delay in how fast that
new M can be created but nevertheless as
an operator you are
not intervening in that equation and
that means that as an application I have
high availability when my primary
instance fails and obviously I have high
availability when my replica fails breed
replica fails
okay so Aurora is good when it comes to
pol tolerance spanner
very similar what spanner does is the
moment any of any one nodes disc Nord
zone or any of those things fail they a
new leader then a new leaders are
elected for all the chunks that were
lost in the remaining existing instances
so the net effect is same it's just that
in spanner be the leader election is
actually much faster compared to what
you would have had in in Aurora because
it is happening at a at a smaller
granularity compared to the entire
instance level so now I if I were
previously writing Row one on instance
one after the failover which is
automatic I will write to wherever Row 1
is now lead at act which let's say
happens to be in the in the second
instance I will write it there from an
application standpoint it's great
because I now can write to it it as if
nothing has happened okay
so both of them are equal but at a high
level when it comes to this then it gets
very interesting now we are talking
about multi region geo distributed
applications and and we want global
consistency I will explain why global
consistency is important so in case of
Aurora if you want to deploy it in a
multi region deployment then you will
have what is known as a multi master
configuration full copy of the data in
one region full copy of data in another
region they both take rights for the
entire data set and that itself is a
problem because the moment you do that
you have to resolve conflicts if the
same key has been updated on two sides
the example is here I'm just changing my
balance deducting $10 from balance on
one side and deducting hundred dollars
of balance on other side in a globally
consistent database the it doesn't
matter which one went first
I want my balance to be deducted 110
dollars at the end of the day in this
one
if balance minus 100 goes first then
that means balance minus 10 goes later
and that's the last writer wins which
means that we we actually lost out on
$100 balance it's and if it's the other
way around we'd lost out and ten dollars
of balance so it is it's easy to build
inconsistent and incorrect applications
in if you deploy or Orionis you're
distributed setting that problem is not
possible in in spanner
because spanner is architected remember
spanner was built in late 2000 hence to
solve the Google AdWords problem where
multiple different marketing managers
are decrementing their ad credits across
the globe so this is the poor foundation
of spanner where irrespective of where
the right is coming from it will be
globally consistent so in this case I
can just talk to my local data center
right
both of them are talking to the local
data center but when this region 3 sees
that the balance key is getting updated
it will automatically send it with
transparently to the application to the
right place and that instance will then
serialize them so the net result will be
balanced minus 110 as the new balance
completely transparent to the
application you don't have to do
anything ok finally this is the last
section from my low read latency now in
case of Aurora load read latency is
given because I
there is only one place where rights are
being taken so if I want correct treats
I should just ask that master and it
will serve me immediately without
looking at anybody else because
technically remember the SQL layer is
not a distributed system the distributed
system is underneath in the storage
layer in spanner there are there are
distributed systems at the upper half
and there is a distributed system at the
lower half and now in a traditional low
sequel database if you know if you want
any kind of better more consistent read
more correct read you have to do
something called as a quorum I have to
go and talk to my replicas to see hey
what values did you see last and then I
have to figure out what was the latest
timestamp and then serve that in this
panel architecture that problem is
avoided by ensuring that each instance
posts the leaders for a certain set of
shots and the moment I ask I put the
right the value for a given key spanner
will automatically route it to the
instance where that key is leader and
you will get the struck the correct read
immediately without talking to anybody
else again very powerful in a in a OLTP
database which has where lots of reads
need to be served typically reads are
significantly higher probably 5 to 10 X
higher than how many writes are served
in any of the applications we use today
that we have come to love pick Netflix
tech take uber take air B&B the read
read volume is much much higher than
your write volume ok with that I have
completed the comparison between Aurora
and spanner want to leave you with this
thought that in the Battle of this
architecture spanner actually beats
Aurora because it is more
general-purpose and allow with the
notion that there is no performance in
our availability bottleneck built into
the system you can actually scale as as
wide as you want and tolerate failures
much more cleanly than you would in
in an Aurora style architecture secondly
it is spanner is built grounder for geo
distributed applications and that
essentially future proofs your your
database from you know ever falling
apart as your business grows into a
global business you may be starting
today in a signal region setting but if
you if if all of us are successful then
it will grow really fast users will come
from all across the globe and you will
not be able to really use the clouds
multi-region capabilities if your
database is not good enough however
spanner is more complex to engineer it's
a harder acknowledge e to build because
of all the things that are going on in
the background it specifically needs
something called as clock skew tracking
and that's what karthik is not talk us
through as to how spanner and some of
the open-source derivatives you go by d
being one of us deal with this kind of a
problem
I think all right thanks it alright hey
guys hopefully I hope everybody's not
sleeping because we're gonna go into a
little bit more detail but you know
we'll try to keep it you know light and
crack a couple of jokes where
appropriate and so on and so forth ok so
to summarize we talked about spanner and
Aurora and we said spanner ensures you
like is more future proof so it's a
database built for the future Aurora is
to simplify your operations today right
that's the head to head and we talked
about some of the key things in spanner
how it does right scalability and geo
distribution and so on so let's look at
the open source derivatives of spanner
first question why do I care about this
well you may be running on AWS
there's no spanner in AWS so what do you
do then right so there's a number of
places where having an open source cloud
neutral database is actually useful you
may want to run this inside containers
inside your company because you're
adopting containers in a big way
kubernetes so so on and so forth so
let's move forward so there are a number
believe it or not of open source
databases that are like google spanner
so there's yoga by TB which we are
working on and there's cockroach TB and
tidy B so these are three of the open
source databases that are
sequel databases distributed sequel
databases built along the lines of
Google spanner so if there's so much of
distributed sequel databases going
around how do you analyze between these
right so that's what we're gonna look at
okay so since we're building yoga by DB
we're pretty confident talking about it
the principles from what we know with
the rest of the databases are quite
similar so you can kind of put it
together in the form of what are some of
the things you need to look at to
analyze databases but let's just take
yoga by DB and draw parallels to the
others but it's quite similar how you
would try and analyze these spanner
derivatives okay what were the design
principles behind yoga bite and again
once again all of this extends to the
other databases as well it's consistent
and partition tolerant in the famous cap
theorem no sequel databases gave up
consistency for availability so see AP
consistency availability and partition
tolerance these databases choose CP but
they still give you high availability
because they replace any failure in a
matter of seconds and modern
applications can experience that sort of
downtime for reasons other than the
database like your internet connectivity
your other application server so on and
so forth
they all have acid transactions single
row and multi row transactions they can
do a variety of different isolation
levels if folks are interested please
drop by the office hours I don't want to
put everybody to sleep and high
performance is a core target for us
because in the cloud you need to be
serving with low latencies it is a top
order concern in the cloud because the
cloud environment is necessarily
commodity and you know noisy and and
finally the aim for all these open
source databases is to be able to run
anywhere like Google spanner only on
Google only a managed service right
there's a number of cases when a managed
service may not be as advantageous as it
sounds because hey I have a networking
issue I have a machine issue sorry you
can't see the machines because it's
managed right and how about you open a
service ticket and and the people will
get back but God knows when that is but
you know you really have to do something
but there's nothing you can do okay
so at a very high level these are the
three big block diagrams that yoga byte
is Bill to solve there is why SQL which
converts your traditional Postgres
sequel
into a distributed sequel query layer so
it deals with the query aspect of the
database there is a distributed document
store that is that forms the core
storage layer of the database and there
is a piece that lets it run on any
hardware whether you're talking about
containers bare metal VMS kubernetes
whatever it is right so it abstracts out
vis so these are the three top level
block diagrams inside the database and
so where does that put us so now that
we've gotten an overview of how this
architecture works let's look
specifically at a few aspects of the
database of of yuga white and compare it
with the other open source spanner
derivatives just so you get an idea of
how these things work so the things
we're gonna look at our sequel features
we're going to look at replication
protocol clock skew tracking thats it
talked about and the transaction manager
how that happens okay and then which is
going to throw something in a
miscellaneous bucket where there could
be various things that some databases
support some don't you just have to look
at those yourself the first thing before
we get started is cost open source
databases are free which makes it a very
attractive price whereas Google spanner
is not and it doesn't matter whether
it's your test data dev data you're
playing with it or you're actually
running it in production it's all the
same so well that's there but anyways
that out of the way let's go to sequel
compatibility so one of the other things
that Sid talked about is Aurora is so
popular because it is fully compatible
with my sequel and Postgres while Google
spanner is not right so what did the
open source folks do well what we did at
Yoga byte was we took the Postgres query
engine and we taught it to talk to a
distributed sequel datastore so on the
left you have a traditional single node
Postgres that talks to a like a disk on
one node and the green portion is the
actual query engine of Postgres we kind
of changed the query engine of Postgres
and converted it to a stateless Postgres
and got that to run on top of a
distributed sequel database so what does
that mean it means we have a spanner
like architectural core but it is fully
Postgres compatible right so we're
trying to bring the best of Aurora
and spanner as our and here are some of
the things that we support inside the
database so most anything you expect
from Postgres you should be able to
expect from us it may just be a point in
our journey whether we support it today
or it's going to be there in a few
months but effectively most of the the
common things that you would expect from
sequel databases so how do the other
open-source databases fare they do
pretty well too cockroach DB is Postgres
compliant and tidy B is my sequel
compliant so everyone made the right
choice in trying to make it simple for
people to adopt right all right so let's
look at replication now how do you
ensure so machines fail of the cloud
right how do you ensure that your data
is still available well you have to
replicate it somewhere now if I write
data on one or more on more than one
machine how do I know that if when my
primary machine dies that the data is
actually consistent right if you're
doing a master slave you're definitely
going to lose some data how do you
ensure that the data is consistent
that's where replication protocols kick
in okay so once again what do we do with
your gabbai we take a table that's what
the thing looks like in the left your
entire table and then we shard it into
small pieces okay so think of a shard as
automatically partitioning your table
into small sets of data so we group rows
into smaller sets and put them according
to some strategy now we take each of
these shards and we put them on across
multiple nodes so every piece of data
being written to a row gets distributed
across nodes right and the real trick is
how do you do it in a way where there's
no inconsistency and you don't lose data
and that's where something like a raft
consensus algorithm comes in like
there's a number of different ways you
can implement consensus but raft is one
of the easiest and most expressive and
one of the additional features raft
gives you is you can actually change the
set of nodes dynamically which means I
can be writing to these three nodes and
I can add a fourth node and remove one
node so what's the implication of that
well you can start with machine type one
your database running on machine type
one you have five nodes
after a like by adding and removing
notes you could be running on five nodes
of machine type - or in a different zone
so that means you don't have to shut
down all your database machines and you
tell somebody you know this is a notice
for downtime of the database please
don't expect expect the service downtime
none of that stuff it just keeps running
all the time right so so it's useful
that way and this is how at a very high
level raft works it looks like every
other quorum system but there is a
difference in how the internals work
once again office hours would be a great
time to talk about it not going into the
details rights go to a leader and are
written to a majority so you're
replicating it three ways but you're
waiting for at least two guys to write
your data and all your reads are handled
directly at the leader so that means if
you're geographically distributed but
you go to the leader which is in your
geography you will get very low latency
response so that talks about the low
latency reads that you get so what do
the others do well no points for
guessing everybody uses Raph because
it's really simple google spanner
started before raft was a thing so it
uses a family of algorithms called Paxos
Paxos is also a legitimate consensus
algorithm except it's very very hard to
understand and that should be pretty
evident by the fact that
paxos came out and then there's actually
a paper called Paxos made simple and
then there's another paper called Paks
was made very simple I'm sure there's
another one called very very simple and
so on so it's just a series of papers
and you know what they finally decided
it wasn't simple enough and people just
created raft and said this is really
simple so so that's what's going on here
okay so we're gonna take the next thing
together because they're kind of related
how do you do transactions and clock
skew tracking okay it's just an
interesting topic in itself what is a
transaction and why do you care about
multi shard or distributed transactions
well I want to update two keys right
take a take the example that's it showed
where you want it to subtract ten
dollars from your account right and you
want it to send it to somebody else's
account so key one is subtract ten
dollars from my account and key two is
say I had ten dollars to say that since
account that's how I transfer money
right you want to do that
transactionally we don't want me losing
the money or him getting the money
without and the bank
using the money so both of those are bad
scenarios so this has to happen
atomically it either happens or it does
it they can be no like it's kind of
written sort of written or one side
written none of that stuff right so key
one and key two may belong to different
charts so they could live on different
nodes right and they could live on
different geographies it doesn't matter
so each of these shards are replicated
across notes so they belong to different
raft groups so the picture starts
looking like this you need to write the
data to one raft group which keeps all
the data replicated and you need to
write key to to another raft group which
keeps all the data of replicator right
okay big deal what's so hard about this
well the problem comes when you say that
the data should actually get be written
at the same time so if I'm a user and I
keep issuing select my balances for key
one and key to or read key one and key
to all the time in a loop
I should see at one instant that key one
and key to are some old value and the
next incident they both are the new
value irrespective of what failure
happens where okay so the hard question
right is how do you get nodes to agree
on time okay seems relatively trivial
just use the clock but it doesn't work
if you use physical clocks they don't
quite agree so you would need an atomic
clock right and this is what famously
Google spanner does they have a true
time service which is powered by a GPS
synchronized atomic clock right if it
sounds fancy that's because it is right
so it's really hard to do that so it is
a globally synchronized clock with tight
error bounds right okay so if people
told you like you know what why don't
you just add an atomic clock or two and
you'll have all of this stuff
well not quite gonna happen that way
most of the clocks that the rest of us
four people have our unsynchronized
clocks they are synchronized but the
upper bound is really high so that means
that you'll get your upper bound at 150
or 200 milliseconds now would you like
every single read and write to take that
long probably not so you either have an
atomic clock or this is there another
option right so there is another option
turns out is a heck of a lot more calm
Gator right so but you know that's what
we do anyway so you know it's it's and
we call it fun too so so it's called
hybrid logical clocks okay so you take
the physical time on these machines
which is coarsely synchronized with that
huge upper bound error limit and within
that time you start doing causal
tracking we use a logical clock in
between right so a happens before B C
happens after B you need to know that
within that time right so you do this by
using a physical and logical tuple right
the physical component coarsely
synchronized using ntp and the logical
component being a monotonic counter to
track causal chains now every exchange
between the nodes keeps updating
physical time and keeps updating this
hybrid logical time so nodes in a
cluster keep normalizing time within
themselves but that still leaves you
with some cases when you really can't
tell there were two updates to two
different nodes that didn't exchange any
conversation with each other right now
in those cases are when you detect what
is called a conflict right so you're
updating a key here and you're updating
a related key on the other node and
you're trying to do that at different
physical times but they're within your
synchronization window and you don't
know how close they are
so what most of these databases do what
yoga white does is it really reduces the
number of times you would conflict right
so it doesn't rely on conflicts it tries
to avoid conflicts but if there is a
necessity for you know detecting a
conflict it tries to maintain
correctness over if like speed right
because we all don't mind if the
transaction takes a little longer but no
one wants to lose their money right so
okay so yeah so what do we do
Google spanner uses true time you know
their own satellites and stuff but you
could bite and cockroach DB use hybrid
logical clock with a max clock skew
right they say that you cannot your
clock skew cannot exceed some bound and
as long as that property holds will keep
doing better and better with most of
your transactions you may never hit in
your application a case when there is
actually a conflict but if you do will
detect it and restart the transaction or
let you know that you know there's
something that's
really off and you have to retry that
transaction ty DB goes a different way
ty DB puts a centralized timestamp
Oracle to issue time that means
everything happening on the distributed
cluster has to go to this centralized
node in order to get time since time is
issued by a centralized entity which is
a highly available entity but it is a
central entity you won't go wrong with
clock skew tracking now different
products optimized for different use
cases so I wouldn't say one is right or
wrong
the downside of going with a centralized
timestamp engine is that it won't work
well for geo distributed use cases
everybody has to keep going back to the
central thing the downside of using the
hybrid logical clock plus max skew is
what happens if your maxxxx queue is
exceeded or how much do you need to wait
if you detect conflicts or those kind of
issues start coming up right so those
well the other thing is that in all the
other designs you are necessarily scaled
out so horizontally scalable whereas in
this case the timestamp issuing
authority is a single Authority right so
okay so there's a miscellaneous bucket
of course we know more about yoga bite
so we're gonna find out a point there
may be many points to the to the
converse so things like tunable read
latency is something that yoga bytes
supports tunable read latency is the
ability to read from a follower node and
Google spanner supports that yoga byte
supports that a cockroach does not we
believe yeah and tidy B for example also
does not but I'm sure there are other
features that other folks support that
we don't but the point here is please do
the research on the exact set of
features these are miscellaneous
features it depends really on exactly
what your application is trying to do
and finally there are these set of tests
called Jepson tests for those of you
that follow databases it is kind of
considered like the best in class to
figure out whether a database is correct
or not and the way it's done is number
of failures are induced on a database
partitions no debts you know all sorts
of crazy things it's it's like the guy
really takes pride in breaking it's the
Kyle the person who does the tests and
he's really good at it too so so he
subjects these databases to all
imaginable failure conditions that you'd
think like you know read something pause
the node right try to write somewhere
else by oh this node introduced a
partition read from this other guy all
of that stuff so spanner obviously
didn't need to do it they've managed to
you know deal with their own ads folks
and ads is a pretty big business for
google if you're thinking Google search
that's their primary bread-and-butter if
they're kept the people happy I think
it's kind of fair to say it's consistent
so they do really well on the
consistency in the face of failures
front but they don't they don't need to
run it through Jepsen however you go
bite and cockroach DB you go by we
recently got ran it through Jepsen and
he was able to verify that for all the
claims that we make the database is
indeed correct and so has cockroach and
tidy B has not I'm sure they've done a
bunch of testing on their own but this
is something like you know hopefully in
the future they will but this is another
thing to look at because the question
often comes up how can I trust a small
company or a new project does it take
ten years or fifteen years to build a
database so the way to do that is
actually test in a very accelerated
fashion with all the errors so that
probabilistically you will not encounter
those errors in production when you're
running it if you like this type of
content there's a whole bunch of stuff
we write please follow our blogs I think
that's it does you go by determine like
algorithmically the partitioning schema
or is that configured by the user
there's a little bit of control for the
user but you could buy algorithmically
determines that and there's always with
expressing intent you can do a lot
better in the database so there are
schemes to express your intent if not it
will default to a particular partition
scheme the partition scheme we support
by default right now is we hash
partition the primary keys and we are
working on support for range
partitioning or in order and you will be
able to choose which one you want to do
and that really depends on your app and
your access pattern
oh yeah yes yeah go for it yeah so I
thought you were always the first one
yeah so Google spanner is expensive but
they do handle the operations what are
kind of the worst case scenarios for
this family of databases if we're
running them ourselves
for example maybe some region goes down
and there's some thundering herd
recovery problem that happens yeah great
question so in the in the case that most
of these databases are meant to be
resilient in order to deploy them you
would have to pick a replication factor
and a certain deployment topology in
order to survive a certain type of
failures as long as the failures are
within the configured bounds you will
have to do nothing extra and the
database will run so that means you
don't have to wake up at 3 a.m. to
rescue you can come at 10 a.m. after
you've had your coffee and actually you
know figure out what to do to rescue it
by adding nodes and so on and so forth
if the failure bounds are outside what
has been configured then obviously it's
a catastrophic failure in that case you
would rely on backups and other ways to
restore it or that actually becomes a 3
a.m. call so
[Music]